[Music]
what do you want stand by the term
animal husbandry by definition it is the
science of breeding and caring for farm
animals what do we mean by breeding and
caring for animals I'm sure you have
studied about hybridization of different
breeds of animals in lower grades why do
we employ techniques of hybridization
the answer is quite simple it is to
ensure good qualities of animals which
proved advantageous to humans what all
does the management of animals then
involves it involves work in three
distinct areas animals need to be fed
breeding of animals is plant and
diseases that attack animals must be
controlled that seems like a lot of work
why do we need animal husbandry as we
know the population of humans is on the
rise it is necessary to provide food for
their needs animal husbandry takes care
of the growing needs of the population
to a large extent animal husbandry
includes different types of occupations
like cattle farming poultry farming and
many more we will study a few in the
lessons that follow in this lesson we
will look at cattle farming which
animals do cattle include cows yes cows
and Bullock's
oxen Bulls are the most common cattle
what purposes do the cattle serve they
are dual purposed and can you guess what
those two purposes are what is the main
thing we get from cattle milk that's
right cattle farming comprises of milk
animals or in simple words animals that
provide us with milk milk as we know is
the crux of the dairy industry a variety
of dairy products require milk as the
raw material however the milking period
of milk animals is very short how to
farmers ensure a constant supply of milk
production throughout the year this can
be done by increasing the lactation
period of these animals
what do we mean by the lactation period
this is the period during which the
mother feeds the young cattle where
would we find the species of cattle do
all species have long lactation periods
unfortunately that is not the case
only exotic breeds of cattle have long
lactation periods such exotic breeds
have many desirable qualities
apart from long lactation periods they
have excellent resistant to diseases
these exotic breeds have been cross bred
to find the ideal type of cattle however
having exotic breeds of cattle does not
ensure good outcomes of cattle farming
cattle need to be taken care of this
involves a lot of efforts on the part of
the owners they need to make adequate
provisions of shelter and food for
animals these shelters must adhere to
basic requirements of Hygiene clean
shelters for instance are a must they
need proper ventilation food on the
other hand must be provided for two
major reasons first food should sustain
their needs for maintenance of the body
secondly additional food must be
provided to suffice their bodily need
for producing milk is there anything
specific that must be given to cattle
well cattle feed must consist of
roughage which is nothing but fiber they
should also be provided with
micronutrients this is with regard to
their food requirements what about the
need to be protected from diseases in
order to protect cattle from diseases
which can be seen as well as those which
are internal cattle must be vaccinated
they must be closely monitored and
proper medical facilities must be made
available to them if all these are in
place cattle farming can be a rewarding
occupation cattle farming does serve the
purpose then what are the purpose thus
cackled farming serves cattles as we
know are used as draft animals Bullock's
oxen and bulls are used for farm labour
what work to cattle do
on the farms they are used for tilling
for driving carts and for irrigation as
well
there are two species of cattle that are
most commonly used do you know what
their scientific names are they are
known as vos indicas cows and vos
boobless buffaloes the names are quite
long aren't they well we can always
refer to them as cattle or cows and
buffaloes with that we have studied
quite a lot about cattle haven't we in
our next video we will look at the idea
of poultry farming trust me you do want
to know about this industry which is
catching up faster than we know
[Music]